[Aplausos]
a pessoa ao vosso lado estivesse nua
seria seria estranho seria
desconfortável
seria engraçado eu vim aqui partilhar
uma pequena história e um pouco do meu
pensamento é que o keno deixa a comissão
for falar da realidade
eu tenho uma iniciativa recentemente
chama-se maputo feira joy é que nós
sentamos como artistas e temos uma
pessoa que posará nua tá nós desenhamos
eu estava muito à vontade com isso
afinal de contas eu sou a cellmania
nudez não sei que é uma pessoa na minha
frente no stress
então eu sinto lata com os meus papéis
dos meus lápis e eu sou catalão no meio
por uma comissão possa começar é de mim
aí a vontade desta não sei que estão
todos preparados e todo o olhar para os
meus papéis muito concentradas e com
dodi pra cima
lá está ela nua sem um pano
sem uma camada ela está confortável
afinal de contas quem está
desconfortável sou eu
vestida então comecei a perguntar a
gente passa por uma pessoa essa pessoa
está confortável no seu próprio corpo
qual é a origem do desconforto que nós
entende a realidade é que nós mexemos
nos isso não é novidade mas é estranho
considerando que ao longo da nossa vida
apesar de terem os lancheiros nos
continuamos já os estímulos de certa
forma a cautela é a morrer
somos entrosados vestidos quando eu era
criança aliás todos nós temos aquela
foto básica em que estamos longe não é -
gil
como podem ver na foto eu fui vítima da
minha mãe que durava meu estilo
quando eu ia brincar eu tinha que usar
meias e até que
só de ver este vestido eu sinto
commission
então isso leva a pensar se toda minha
infância eu passei de esquerda como é
que eu entrasse com os outros eu tive
aquela experiência brincar na lama entre
larm
como é que um lance ano com meu próprio
corpo
nós cobrimos escondemo-nos e chama nos
mudamos a forma como nós vemos os outros
por enquanto fala da onu deixe a
vergonha
fala-se do pudor a mesma vergonha que
nos faz pensar que uma pessoa rua que
está nua deve ser maluca porque não é
possível não é normal uma pessoa estar
nua
nós que estamos aqui quanto tempo é que
nós passamos a conviver com o nosso
corpo como viemos da terra antes e
depois do banho quanto tempo é que nós
passamos para observar o desenvolvimento
do nosso próprio corpo quando se pensa
na nudez quantos de nós já estamos a
pensar em coisas e indecentes
estamos a reunir conosco mesmo porque
não sabemos como reagir a isso
a vergonha meus amigos não é algo que
nasce connosco a vergonha é algo que nós
damos por nós não falamos disso existem
muitas histórias de como a vergonha seja
homem
muitos descrevem este momento este
encontro da humanidade ea vergonha como
a maior ruptura que já aconteceu entre
nós em nosso corpo mas já estou aqui
para lançar um desafio ao qual é
proposta que eu estou não estou a dizer
que absorvam só tem ficar nua mas podem
fazer o que quiserem
a proposta que os dez primeiro dispostos
a desistir não significa apenas tirar a
roupa
despir significa ficar num virar os
esteriótipos tirar as inseguranças tirar
os pensamentos que não são fundamentados
despir significa encontrar falar e
procurar nas pessoas
interações que tem mais valor interações
que não são cobertas com coisas que nós
não sabemos o espírito significa abrir
nós vivemos agora numa era digital em
que todas as ferramentas que nós criamos
vem para cumprir aquilo que nós somos
naturalmente bons a fazer que é
interagir com seres humanos e pessoal
a realidade é que no fim do dia nós
morremos nos obrigado
[Aplausos]